So it has to be said.
John Bolton is a traitor to the interests
of the United States.
I believe John Bolton's absolutely stunning
claims in his book about Donald Trump.
I believe John Bolton is telling the truth
as he sees it, and that the stories he tells
in the book are mostly accurate.
I believe Trump okayed wigger concentration
camps in China.
I believe Trump said invading Venezuela is
cool.
I believed from past China for help getting
reelected, I believe.
Trump said reporters should be imprisoned
direct secuity.
I believe Trump didn't know that the UK had
nuclear weapons.
Why do I believe it?
Because it passes the sniff test and it correlates.
It seems to be corroborated by three and a
half years of similar claims about Donald
Trump by people who have been around him.
But John Bolton is a traitor.
Why is John Bolton a traitor?
Because he waited seven months to make these
claims in public.
Now you're going to see criticisms of Bolton
and of people on the left who essentially
believe Bolton is in broad strokes telling
the truth here.
You're starting to see some people on the
left say, you idiot leftists, you fell for
the fake Russia story.
You fake fell for the fake Ukraine story.
You fell for impeachment, which was which
was never going to remove Donald Trump, which
we said, by the way.
And now you're falling for the same type of
nonsense from a horrible guy who is a terrible
neo con and led us into war with Iraq and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
No, no, no, no, no.
That's not the case that John Bolton does
not get a pass here.
But just because someone's a terrible person
doesn't mean everything they're saying is
untrue.
These allegations that John Bolton is making
are so serious that it is an inexcusable miscarriage
of morality for him to have waited seven months
before going public.
Now I get it.
Bolton has a book to sell.
You monetize what you know.
And it made sense financially for him to wait.
Number two, the book was being vetted.
So conceivably, if Bolton just goes public
with all of this stuff in December when the
manuscript was turned over to the National
Security Council and it hasn't yet been vetted,
maybe there's a legal issue or whatever the
case may be.
But John Bolton wants us to believe that he's
doing this because it's for the good of the
country to know what Donald Trump has been
up to behind the scenes.
Well, I agree.
But if his concerns are the good of the country,
we should have known about it seven months
ago or eight or nine months ago or, you know,
a lot of the stuff happened even earlier.
And John Bolton could have talked about it
at the time.
I cannot forgive John Bolton for that.
If five percent of what Bolton claims in the
book is true, there would have been multiple
cases for impeaching Donald Trump.
Now, with a Republican controlled Senate,
Trump still wouldn't have been convicted and
removed on impeachment.
But John Bolton has criticized Democrats for
not going after Trump more strongly on more
issues on impeachment.
Well, he could have told us what some of those
issues were.
He refused to testify before the House impeachment
committee unless he was subpoenaed, which
is not uncommon.
But again, if Bolton is the patriot who's
telling us this because the country deserves
to know, he could have figured out a way to
tell us the seven, eight, nine months ago,
aside from testifying at any point in time,
John Bolton could have said, you know what?
This is so serious.
This is so important that I am going to take
a personal legal risk and I'm going to do
interviews and I'm going to talk about what
I saw.
He still could have written a book.
People still would have bought the book.
Seven months later.
But he could have given us seven months of
a head start and many things could have gone
differently in the last seven months.
Bolton writes in his book that when he saw
Trump ask China for help getting reelected,
he believed it was a threat to American interests.
And he said nothing.
He was national security adviser.
His concern is national security.
And he said nothing about something that he
believed to be a threat to U.S. interests.
Bolton, the patriot, sees a threat, is in
charge of national security and waits to publish
a book in order to go public.
That is not patriotic.
So Bolton going public on all this stuff,
as Eli Hoenig wrote in an op ed for CNN, Bolton
could have changed the course of history had
he gone public seven months ago with this
stuff.
So do I believe Bolton is making this stuff
up?
I don't.
I believe Bolton is telling the truth as he
sees it, and that the book is mostly accurate.
Maybe there are some details that are not
because all of the claims line up with what
we've known about Donald Trump for three and
a half years.
None of these claims seem outlandish in the
context of what we know about Donald Trump.
But in the same way that Don.
John Bolton betrayed.
The country in 2003 by pushing the Iraq war.
Bolton betrayed the United States by waiting
seven months to make these claims public.
These are things that he knew would have been
worthy of impeachment.
And he waited for the opportunity to make
money by selling books.
Now, let's get back to what I know many of
you are going to say.
Why does it matter about impeachment?
Impeachable claims?
If a Republican Senate would not have removed
Trump either way, that is true.
But it would have been much worse for the
Senate to acquit Trump in light of five impeachable
offenses, most of them even crazier than the
Ukraine story.
Then to impeach, then to acquit Trump only
on the Ukraine story.
Trump directly asked China for support getting
reelected.
He told China concentration camps are the
right thing to do.
Trump obstructed investigations into Turkish
individuals and businesses as a favor to Ardo
on seeing Republicans acquit.
Trump, in light of five solid impeachment
cases, might have been a difference maker
in some of the upcoming reelection campaigns
of senators in November.
That's one example.
That would be a material difference.
There is no way that Bolton going public earlier
helps Trump and it might have hurt Trump and
it might have hurt Republicans hugely.
So Bolton was and still is an outrageous warhawk
who wants to see American military personnel
in more places around the world for corporate
profits or neoconservative political goals.
John Bolton probably is at least partially
motivated by a bruised ego related to how
everything went down with Donald Trump.
But John Bolton is not going to just make
up everything that he said in the book.
And yet he is still a traitor.
The right thing to do, if it's out of love
of country would have been for him to make
these claims publicly seven months ago.
He cannot be forgiven for that.
But that doesn't mean what he's saying in
the book is untrue.
And a lot of these lame, just lame, lame,
lame, hot takes from some supposed leftists
completely ignore that Bolton can be a bad
guy.
And the claims can still be true.
Trump can have done the things Bolton alleges.
And yet it could still have been wrong for
Bolton to make the case to go into Iraq, which
it was wrong.
And I hope that we don't see much of the left
go down this very, very wrong headed rabbit
hole.
Let's take a quick break.
We will talk about the economy.
Coming up, we will talk about Corona virus.
A lot more news in the last 24 hours than
merely johnboat The David Pakman Show David
Pakman dot.com.